[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you bad [ __ ]
BAM uncle Joey here and beautiful
Indianapolis is the last show the first
show was tremendous this was sold out
you [ __ ] up
but not really because we get to smoke a
number look what I got here I read it to
you know what they say you just can't
eat one anyway
Timmy Holloway live in Secaucus water
boxer all you [ __ ] making it
happen Saturday night what the [ __ ] you
still doing home you should be out
getting your pipes cleaned and ship it
out looking at your fat [ __ ] uncle
Joey but that's good too you don't
saying we can start again mmm
boom good to the last drop you
understand where they were in my pocket
melting cultivate THC I'll be ready in
45 to kill these [ __ ] gangsta
style anyway did you bring along with
you you [ __ ] showing up empty-handed
like a [ __ ] month a yard I got a
little candle here so we can smoke
what's up you bad [ __ ] you put
Yonko forgot about you huh
never never you understand me you're my
[ __ ] lifeline you [ __ ] this is
the last bone of that [ __ ] I brought
with me this is this [ __ ] that killed
principal they found this [ __ ] next to
his bed with them you gotta take a
chance it's good reefer when that gets
too deep deep in the [ __ ] got get
chewin throw all these [ __ ] I
got a sore throat for me and [ __ ] me I
like your hair so I'm whistling Dixie
the next day dawg you know why
my metabolism is a savage I swam in the
Hudson River you see there I'm thinking
what am I gonna do tonight well this is
the way to start the night off with
uncle Joey he you gonna see the devil ah
that's it
no drama ain't showing I'm at a
restaurant yeah
showing you my buddies just me and you
[ __ ] old school I don't bring
nobody to conversation I don't want
nobody here what the [ __ ] I gotta say to
you just shoot [ __ ]
take a picture with david spade's to
show you guys I don't give a [ __ ]
understand me this is flavor the marines
of comedy is [ __ ] dropping bombs on your
mom's [ __ ] car lawns this reef is
tremendous as you can tell I'm getting
[ __ ] up already smoking reefer with no
water like a [ __ ] like a seal
underwater you follow me I love you guys
always I love when you [ __ ] join in
and we get the smoke of [ __ ] Diablo
together you go back with your life no
big deal no big [ __ ] deal you know
next week I'm in San Francisco with
Andrew but we got that in Sacramento at
the punchline and a week after that
I'm at the Pittsburgh [ __ ] funny bone
you understand me all the improv
whatever the [ __ ] it is I'll be in
Pittsburgh that's all you need to know
with the Penguins hanging out who's one
of my favorite things in the world is
small gonna join my [ __ ] family
remember I'm with you you were me and
they're with us so they want to be with
us but they can't get in
was a deep deep oh say can you see
[Music]
sometimes I get stoned they sing show
tunes sometimes I sing the national
anthem sometimes I sing the our Father
in Latin oh I love you guys
this is what it's all about no drama
just us smoking a number talking to each
other like gentlemen here that's it like
I'm not I got the church on Monday we
have to church on Thursday or Wednesday
with Andrew Dice Clay we got a lot of
[ __ ] cracking this week that you don't
[ __ ] know but you know why you don't
know cuz nobody told you I'm shooting my
special in Chicago did you guys know
that no you did this no you did dad now
you [ __ ] know oh yeah
some of us small gonna drink by yourself
understand me you start listening to
nature you can hear [ __ ]
hmm he's those skinny joints they
[ __ ] kick like a mule sometimes you
know I'm saying you gotta get the right
roll up baby these are tremendous 1
paper rolls no filter not to be no
[ __ ] Johnny look at mine Johnny I got
a filter get the [ __ ] out of my face
that's it let's say you bad
[ __ ] I'm back in LA tomorrow
relaxin I'll be at the store Tuesday
night that's it that's it that's that
tonight sold out thank you very much so
we got four stars of us 800 milligrams
like 92 joints and my blood pressure
medication who's better than me
you that's who besides that I love you
[ __ ]
don't say I think um busy it'll say joy
where the [ __ ] you've been I showed up
like a vampire understand we have loved
you [ __ ]
I'll see you guys tomorrow at some point
of the day wait do you see the reefer I
got a little home waiting for you want
to [ __ ] I got some shroom it's for
this weekend we're going deep into the
murky waters at the end of the world
don't tell nobody I didn't tell you tip
if you don't know now you know
[ __ ] I love you have a good night
be safe
keep your eyes open stay pliable Joey
[ __ ] loves you